Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Three: the government, the prime minister, and the courts.
After an election, someone has to actually run the country.
That is the job of the government, the regering, which holds the executive power.
It administers and puts legislation into effect.
But the government also drafts by far the most bills.
In that way, the government normally has the decisive influence on the political agenda, that is, on which current political themes are debated.
The government is led by the prime minister, the statsminister, and consists of ministers from one or more parties.
In Danish, a majority government is a flertalsregering, and a minority government is a mindretalsregering.
The parties in the Folketing which together hold government power are called the government parties.
If the government parties together have a majority in the Folketing, we speak of a majority government.
One example of a majority government was the government of 2022 to 26, which consisted of the Social Democrats, Venstre and the Moderates.
Other examples were the government of 1978 to 79, which consisted of the Social Democrats and Venstre and was therefore called the SV government, and a government in 1993 to 94 with the Social Democrats and three smaller parties.
Since the Second World War, however, the vast majority of governments have been so-called minority governments.
A government is called a minority government if it consists of parties which together do not have such a majority, and therefore need votes from other parties in the Folketing when it needs to build a majority behind its proposals.
The parties outside the government which support a minority government are called support parties.
Members of the Folketing and parties outside the government who are opponents of the government are called the opposition.
Since June 2026, Denmark has had a minority government consisting of the Social Democrats, SF, the Moderates and the Social Liberal Party, the government parties.
The Red-Green Alliance and the Alternative are the government's support parties, while the centre-right parties, Venstre, Liberal Alliance, the Danish People's Party, the Conservative People's Party, the Denmark Democrats and the Citizens' Party, make up the opposition.
On the third of June, 2026, a new government stepped out onto Amalienborg Palace Square after being presented to the king.
In the front row were the party leaders of the four government parties: Lars Løkke Rasmussen of the Moderates, Mette Frederiksen of the Social Democrats, Pia Olsen Dyhr of SF, and Martin Lidegaard of the Social Liberal Party.
Here are the Danish party names you will see on the exam.
Socialdemokratiet, the Social Democrats.
Venstre.
Radikale Venstre, the Social Liberal Party.
Det Konservative Folkeparti, the Conservative People's Party.
SF, Socialistisk Folkeparti.
Moderaterne, the Moderates.
Liberal Alliance.
Dansk Folkeparti, the Danish People's Party.
Enhedslisten, the Red-Green Alliance.
Alternativet, the Alternative.
Danmarksdemokraterne, the Denmark Democrats.
And Borgernes Parti, the Citizens' Party.
The Folketing's four oldest parties, the Social Democrats, Venstre, the Social Liberal Party and the Conservative People's Party, are also the four parties which have been government parties for clearly the most years in total.
That is why these four parties are often referred to as the "government-bearing" parties.
Three parties, the Moderates, the Socialist People's Party and Liberal Alliance, have all been a government party for a shorter period, all under five years.
And five parties, the Denmark Democrats, the Red-Green Alliance, the Alternative, the Danish People's Party and the Citizens' Party, have never been part of a government.
Now to a key habit of Danish politics.
Since the present election system in its basic structure came about in 1920, no single party has had a majority in the Folketing.
That has created a tradition of the parties trying to agree with each other on how political questions should be solved.
Politicians and parties with very different views and interests often have to talk their way to a compromise that can gather the necessary majority in the Folketing.
And the Folketing passes most laws with a broad majority, which means that the vast majority of its members typically vote in favour.
This tradition of broad agreement and cooperation has been called the cooperating democracy, samarbejdende folkestyre.
It is an important characteristic of the political culture in Denmark.
The politician who, after a general election, has the possibility to form a government is appointed prime minister.
The prime minister is the highest political leader in the country.
It is normally the leader of the largest of the political parties in the government who is appointed prime minister, but it does not have to be so.
A leader of a smaller party can also become prime minister.
For example, Hilmar Baunsgaard of the Social Liberal Party was prime minister from 1968 to 1971.
His party was the smallest party in the government, which also consisted of Venstre and the Conservative People's Party.
What is decisive is that the person does not have a majority against them in the Folketing.
And here are the numbers on who has held the top job.
From the Change of System, Systemskiftet, in 1901 up to 2026, the Social Democrats have held the post of prime minister for a total of 63 years, Venstre for 37 years, the Social Liberal Party for 12 years, and the Conservative People's Party for 10 years.
The other parties in the present Folketing have never held the post of prime minister.
The prime minister appoints the other ministers, who get the leadership and the highest responsibility for each their own area.
In principle, it is the individual minister who sets the government's policy in their own area of work.
In practice, it happens in close cooperation with the rest of the government, among other things at government meetings, where the prime minister has the decisive word.
Every minister has a ministry with many civil servants who help the minister in their work.
This applies, for example, when a bill is to be drawn up.
The civil servants in a ministry are employed on the basis of their professional qualifications.
In Denmark there is no tradition of appointing civil servants based on which party they support.
That is for example the case in the USA.
The Danish civil servants are neutral, and they keep their jobs even if a new government comes in.
However, each minister can themselves appoint between one and three so-called special advisers, who are employed in the ministry to give the minister political advice, for example in relation to the Folketing, the rest of the government and the media.
The special advisers are often appointed because they agree with the minister's policy, and unlike the other civil servants, they leave their jobs when a new minister comes in.
The number of ministers is not fixed, but decided by the prime minister.
Since the year 2000, there have been between 17 and 25 ministers in each government.
It can happen that a minister leads several ministries at once.
No formal qualifications are required to become a minister.
Most have, however, great political experience.
A minister does not have to be a member of the Folketing.
Recent examples of ministers appointed without being members of the Folketing are Stephanie Lose of Venstre, who was chair of the regional council in Region of Southern Denmark and was appointed minister for economic affairs in 2023, and Maria Reumert Gjerding of SF, who was president of the Danish Society for Nature Conservation when she became minister for the environment in 2026.
If a minister is not a member of the Folketing, they cannot take part in the Folketing's votes.
A minister does, however, always have access to take part in the Folketing's meetings, and of course must also present bills at the Folketing's podium within their ministerial area.
The Prime Minister's Office is in Prince Jørgen's Courtyard at Christiansborg Palace in Copenhagen.
The Folketing is elected for a period of at most four years at a time.
The prime minister can call a new election at any time during an election period.
This is called the right of dissolution, opløsningsretten, and is the prime minister's weapon against the Folketing.
Because if an election is called, the voters must once more decide who is to be elected.
A new election is often called at a time when there is good support for the government's policy among the voters, and the government thus has good chances of being re-elected.
But it can also happen if the Folketing votes down a government on an important political question.
It is then left to the voters to take a stand on whether they wish to support the government's or the opposition's policy in that area.
After a new election, the prime minister can continue if they still do not have a majority against them in the Folketing.
There is no limit to how many election periods a prime minister may be in power.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Can the prime minister appoint a minister who is not a member of the Folketing?
Option A: No.
Option B: Yes.
[DA] Kan statsministeren udpege en minister, der ikke er medlem af Folketinget?  A: Nej  |  B: Ja
The answer is B: Yes.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in May 2024.
[DA] ✔ B: Ja
Question 2.
Can a person be prime minister for more than two election periods?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan man være statsminister i mere end to valgperioder?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2020, November 2022 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 3.
Can a government consist of one or more parties that together do not have a majority in the Folketing?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan en regering bestå af et eller flere partier, der ikke tilsammen har flertal i Folketinget?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2020, November 2021 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 4.
Which type of government has been most common in Denmark since the Second World War?
Option A: Minority governments, mindretalsregeringer.
Option B: Majority governments, flertalsregeringer.
[DA] Hvilken type regering har været mest almindelig i Danmark siden 2. Verdenskrig?  A: Mindretalsregeringer  |  B: Flertalsregeringer
The answer is A: Minority governments, mindretalsregeringer.
It appeared in the June 2021 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Mindretalsregeringer
Question 5.
Who can, independently of others, call a general election before the end of the four-year election period?
Option A: The Speaker of the Folketing.
Option B: The prime minister.
[DA] Hvem kan uafhængigt af andre udskrive folketingsvalg inden udløbet af den 4-årige valgperiode?  A: Folketingets formand  |  B: Statsministeren
The answer is B: The prime minister.
It appeared in the June 2020 and November 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Statsministeren
Question 6.
Which party has held the post of prime minister for the most years in total since the Change of System in 1901?
The options are Venstre and the Conservative People's Party.
Option A: Venstre.
Option B: The Conservative People's Party.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende partier har haft statsministerposten i sammenlagt flest år siden Systemskiftet i 1901?  A: Venstre  |  B: Det Konservative Folkeparti
The answer is A: Venstre.
It appeared in the November 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Venstre
Question 7.
Which of the following parties has been in government for the most years in total?
Option A: The Socialist People's Party, SF.
Option B: The Social Liberal Party, Radikale Venstre.
Option C: The Danish People's Party.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende partier har samlet set været i regering flest år?  A: Socialistisk Folkeparti  |  B: Radikale Venstre  |  C: Dansk Folkeparti
The answer is B: The Social Liberal Party, Radikale Venstre.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Radikale Venstre
That's the end of Part One of Episode 3.
In Part Two, we continue with the courts, domstolene.
See you there.